une stratégie des Russes accusée les
Ukrainiens de préparer une bombe dite
sale c'est-à-dire composée de matériaux
radioactifs après les Indiens le
ministre russe de la Défense a échangé
sur le sujet avec les Chinois ce
mercredi une manière de gagner du temps
et de masquer ses défaites sur le
terrain car les Ukrainiens avancent
notamment vers Carson ville occupé par
les Russes on retrouve dans la région
notre envoient spéciale Jonathan Wolf
bonjour Jonathan vous avez suivi une
unité de l'armée ukrainienne entre
nicolaïve et Carson racontez-nous ce que
vous avez vu
exactement nous avons suivi toute la
journée une unité Darty heure de l'armée
ukrainienne une unité comme il en existe
des dizaines qui opèrent en ce moment
dans cette contre-offensive vers Herson
je me trouve actuellement sur leur base
arrière à une quarantaine de kilomètres
à peu près à l'ouest à l'ouest de
airsson et nous avons pu observer toute
la journée le même processus se répétait
l'unité est contactée par le
commandement qui a préalablement repéré
des cibles à l'aide de drones et ils
sont envoyés sur une position précise
pour frapper ses cibles derrière moi
vous pouvez voir un des canons de 152 mm
qui sont utilisés par cette unité nous
avons pu les suivre lors de l'une de ces
opérations ils ont tiré à peu près une
vingtaine de une vingtaine d'obus pour
frapper ses cibles d'après ce qu'ils
nous ont dit il s'agissait de véhicules
blindés et de troupes russes et toujours
d'après ce qu'ils nous ont dit ils ont
réussi à frapper les ceux qui leur avait
été donné par leur commandement pour ce
qui est de l'avancée et de cette
contre-offensive vers Herson vous le
savez il est très difficile d'avoir des
informations précises à ce sujet l'armée
communique très peu en tout cas nous
avons évidemment posé la question aux
commandants de l'unité d'artilleur que
nous accompagnons aujourd'hui et il se
montre comme tous les officiers de
l'armée ukrainienne très optimiste il
dit même que l'objectif n'est pas
seulement de reprendre personne mais
également la Crimée et il espère il
espère que la criminée pourra être
reprise rapidement mais on le sait le
compte le compte à rebours est toujours
et toujours en cours puisque il y a un
objectif simple pour l'armée ukrainienne
aujourd'hui qui est de reprendre rerson
avant l'hiver merci beaucoup Jonathan
wall je suis envoyé spécial